[Music]
bunch of wealthy homeowners are a little
bit pissed off because there's a bunch
of affordable housing being built nearby
that happens all the time oh it [ __ ]
with their value what do you do what do
you do bart quan take it away you're the
wealthiest
well no he's the wealthiest so you go
first and then bark can go according to
this yeah
you're you're 19 million so go ahead so
what do i do if they're building
sections dirty dirty
uh affordable housing people they're
trying to build near you these nasty
poor that's gonna [ __ ] with your value
like if you even lose like four percent
on your house like that's gonna be
[ __ ] devastating did they get the
contract from the city to build already
yes so they're gonna start building i'll
[ __ ] buy those homes before they
could the other people can damn that's
expensive though think about it i
thought i was rich yeah but
you're rich asset rich
not cash rich yeah so i can't buy it so
i so the only option is you carry it or
you sabotage it karen
how are you carrying a joe you create a
petition against it and if enough people
sign and then you enough people complain
to the city hall
they can't do it interesting
that's the right way to do it ryan yeah
you're the richest here according to
celebrity net worth
uh what can you to stop it from being
built or to wow yeah [ __ ] um salt the
earth
just make it uh make the land infertile
so it's worthless holy [ __ ] your vicious
[ __ ] doesn't that [ __ ] up your land
as well
only i know that it's salted
okay according to celebrity net worth
you're next up
mine was uh i was just gonna save up
like three months worth of [ __ ]
and then just [ __ ] sprinkle it in the
houses every now and then where would
you store it some people were like what
the [ __ ] just people coming in there
[ __ ] in these guys [ __ ] going on we
made us a better abandon this project
and i'm like that's right and then as
soon as i hear them say that the next
day double down on the amount of [ __ ]
that's in there anthony lee you're next
up joe not so fast you're only worth
five hundred thousand quarter slider
network
probably uh
probably hire everybody that is going to
move into that space and so they can
afford more and then they have to move
out to like nicer places
spoken like a dancer there's a new wave
of people that'll come in the place
figured out what to really do what would
it really do think of this okay all you
got to do
is say that that was a burial ground
poor people are superstitious that's
awesome they won't want to live there
only do believe in spirits
that's really good that's why i'm poor
no okay
joe i guess we'll let you go but for
time you got to make it quick
[Laughter]
be a normal human being
and hire the mob the higher the mall
hire the mob when you don't want things
to happen and the city's not listening
then you hire the mob to destroy their
construction contract that's your time
oh so you're just gonna muster that's
gonna be my future house dude you can't
be doing this [ __ ] i'm gonna be living
in those people on capitol hill that's
your time thank you very much that's
your time
cut his microphone cut his microphone
get him out of here get him out of here
cut his [ __ ] mic
we got his net worth cut his mic
so so what they do
we let him bounce back in because he's
worth 90 mil and he's like i just real
quick i had a different idea i also said
oh yeah both viable as well yeah our
sponsor wants to speak again go ahead
no here's my third solution so
officials in this enclave so this is
like group of like 500 people they
announced that all of woodside was
exempt from a new state uh low-income
housing law that allows for duplex
development on single-family home lots
because the entire town is habitat for
potentially endangered mountain lions
whoa okay they've already built out
their places okay like you know they're
already they're just and they're
starting to grapple with the realization
that like oh my god there's like
endangered mountain lions here so we
can't have new developments so you're
going the eco route [ __ ] with
everything eco guilt
so that's very effective knock all those
homes down or
you can't even know they're just going
to stop anything new exactly so they're
trying to to stop it from even breaking
ground i feel like hollywood hills did
that same show if you had the info then
this is what you do you go in there you
kill all the mountain lions
no problem
yeah that's if you were poor yeah so if
you're a poor you do that so then you
can build you could get you could get
one of the affordable housings in a rich
neighborhood yeah if it's it's not
endangered if it's not living
yeah it's just extinct
now what are they going to do
yeah that's interesting i wouldn't kill
them
advocates are saying that the um the
huge mansions that these people inhabit
in the mountain lion endangered species
zone is ironic because it's like well if
that's true this is bad karma for the
rich people because now the mountain
lions are going to go into their homes
and start but they're just saying no
more homes right yeah they're like we
already already [ __ ] maxed it out
that's what's up i feel like that's the
same [ __ ] in hollywood hills they're
saying that the balance of nature to
home is now at a limit where we can't
have any more homes there's a lot of
homes up there yeah but then the people
that are advocating for no more homes
means their value is going to skyrocket
because now there's no more that can be
built that's like the homes in like
monrovia and what's that baller ass
bradbury up there you know what the door
to whatever hill same deal i feel like
that happens every time they go oh
that's enough no more houses sorry yes
look at that [ __ ] so i do this all the
time huh the immediate home value in
this area is 4.5 million dollars
so what is a low income home then two
million oh yeah i want these blips
[Laughter]
it's only for startup guys
uh so among the residents are uh
founders of
intuit which is like a
yeah a huge company intel symantec as
well as larry ellison where where is
this yeah where is this silicon valley
[ __ ] washington it's called woodside
it's like a silicon valley suburb oh
oh
i wonder what their house is damn
yeah 4.5 is the median must be a [ __ ]
big-ass commute for anybody that does
like landscaping or like maids and [ __ ]
or uh housekeepers yeah
can you imagine living in those um
volleyballer homes where you have a
living staff like have you ever seen
like those houses in england or they're
not even homes they're like castles
right it's like a hundred and something
rooms it's been in people's families for
like 500 years and then you'll see like
one [ __ ] lord or one dude lives there
and no family no relatives but like a
hundred staff people yeah that's pretty
crazy yeah that's nuts are they all like
nuts hello sir when you walk in yeah in
the cornucopia you just got [ __ ]
dudes that live there so they could cut
the lawn and then they can't even finish
it like it's a it's a whole 40 hour work
week where you cut the lawn all day trim
great by the time you're done with it
you got to cut it yeah yeah again
because it grew
that's wild dude loop yeah yeah
or by the time you're done cutting it's
like winter you don't have to worry
about anymore can you guys respond
have live and help like do you think you
could ever do that it seems like fresh
prince i don't know if i like that
you would do like an in-law maybe but i
would love to have an in-law but like
having like i enslaved my family all day
but when it comes to strangers that's
where i draw the line yeah what if it's
like that's why the asian culture of
like getting someone really close to
your culture like would you get a
japanese guy nope because they [ __ ]
too perverted
that's the reason you think you're
jerking
all right what kind of asian would you
like them
to live in your house what's the least
perverted asian uh chinese people don't
[ __ ] that much but there is a billion of
them so i might be lying
um they just make it count they just
make it count the evidence
you know what i'll just go with food and
i would say i love vietnamese food so i
would get a vietnamese grandma
but i have a feeling she's gonna yell at
you she's gonna start being too
comfortable and start bossing me around
being nosy and start giving her opinions
she's going to start talking [ __ ] this
guy hates
grandpa
dude i didn't hire you to be my mom dude
like
she gonna do your nails you know what i
would have to do southeast asian because
the food the food is just so different
from east asian
yeah
because my friend um always had like a
living like help that he lived in san
marino [ __ ] nice ass neighborhood big
ass home
i walk around
they had to cook
and they also had like um like a maid
and then so if we do sleepovers or
whatever like they always cook for us it
was pretty cool but i always thought it
was so weird to have somebody that isn't
a part of your family living inside of
your house what's your favorite
southeast asian dish
oh man it would have to be something
between like a food
or between that uh this malaysian thing
it was this like rice mix something
i forgot nasi malacca
but a part of me wants to experience
that i want to know what it's like to
have like live and help to have like a
staff where you just wake up and they're
already [ __ ] getting food ready all
this stuff is like you know
and i want to know what that's like i
bet it's pretty sick yeah it must be
great how about it sucks out yeah
no i don't think that
there's nobody get a servant i wonder
what that's like oh yeah it's awesome
actually go figure i can't believe that
that that's awesome but i also like
people all up in my business too so i
don't know well but isn't your house
being i think i've been to your house
yeah it's a thing how do you even know
someone else is there i don't know i
just don't like people like like hearing
a story or something like i can't wait
to go gossip this somewhere else that's
why they gotta not be able to speak or
understand english you know what i mean
you just point this stuff in there like
when i was watching the rams game with
captain america and he's talking to his
chick about how he just went hunting and
i'm like
i can kind of hear you dude
[Laughter]
yeah it's like weird that else would be
kind of crazy can you be yourself and
relax because that's what you could kind
of hear yourself that's the thing my
grandma grew up like that and she says
every [ __ ] morning from monday
through friday right everyone got ready
they had breakfast together and then
they would have to line up in the
driveway to see off my grandpa
and his driver would get the yeah that's
all right that's dope man they all
[ __ ] bowed the staff all the it was a
hierarchy mom
kids and the staff and then they would
[ __ ] bow and every single that was
their thing every single morning
righteous gems so i was like i was like
that's crazy and then you lived with
them and then they it's like
that's so weird to me they're not family
members i don't know it could be fun
what if you like play games with them in
the backyard and stuff you know
if you like treat them like friends what
if they're so poor that's like um
i always wanted a human table
like i wanted someone on all fours where
i put a table on their back
and then i i eat food i thought that
would be pretty funny so he doesn't want
to live with servants but wants a human
table i would love a human table i would
love it would you have them human foot
rest or no i want them to pretend that
they're a dog for a table oh
with a bunch of fruits all over the
privates and stuff like that
that's kind of sexual
here's what i want to
the gardeners were doing it
look i want this person to be a human
table and then
i want to move out of my property
but then like on moving day i want this
person to still pretend to be a table so
they don't get up and then the movers
have to move them you have to wrap them
with plastic
the rock and roll movers this is like
squid game you guys can squish it you're
standing there and you're going oh i
don't know
don't [ __ ] up my wall man
come on
you